The US Federal Reserve.
The Bank of England.
The European Central Bank: the world over,
central banks are some of the most powerful
institutions.
Their arsenal allowing them to adjust interest
rates, inflation, print money, and shore up
the economy.
And they are usually designed to be INDEPENDENT
from political inteference.
But is that changing?
Applause, handshakes and backslaps aside,
President Trump hasn't proved to be the biggest
fan of Fed Chair Jerome Powell ... criticising
the US Federal Reserve's decision to raise
rates, on several occasions:
I think the Fed has gone crazy.
I really disagree with that they are doing.
I think the Fed is out of control.
What they are doing is wrong.
And they are making a mistake.
But Donald Trump isn't the only one questioning
monetary decisions.
Turkish President Recep Tayyip Erdogan is
at the forefront of attacks against his country's
Central Bank:
He remains vehemently against raising borrowing
costs which is believed to be the reason the
bank hasnt increased them.
And in India, the Central Bank Governor there
unexpectedly resigned on Monday.
Urjit Patel had been embroiled in a series
of clashes with Prime Minister Modi's administration
... putting the Reserve Bank of India under
intense pressure to ease lending conditions.
Experts warn of real economic risks
Still for now, it seems there's a global tussle
over WHO gets the keys their country's
monetary policy.